associate director and I'd like to
welcome you to our Ninth Annual industry
day and thank you to many of you who
participate in the life of the Institute
um industry partners program organizers
scientific collaborators research
fellows um if you're new to the Simons
Institute which I imagine many of you
are not but just in case um we uh
provide a collaborative platform for for
research in uh Computing Theory and
adjoining Fields the main stay of our
scientific programming is that we run
two semester long programs around
various themes related to computer
science and related areas and we bring
together a diverse community of
researchers from around the world in
theoretical computer science Engineers
mathematicians and experts in other
adjoining Fields such as social sciences
economics and law um we facilitate
research that has a wide- ranging impact
and it's supported by many of our valued
industry Partners such as yourselves um
and I'd like to particularly recognize
our friends at Apple Google VMware Rock
360 relational Ai and aloran for your
partnership and if you're an industry
scientist and would like to know more
about our partnership program please let
us know um our Partnerships offer a
variety of benefits that are designed to
meet the individual needs of our
partners so let's get things underway um
I hope you have access to the digital
schedule um it includes speaker names
talk titles and abstracts but here's a
little bit of an overview we're going to
start off the morning with an overview
of our current and future uh programs at
the Simons Institute um and we'll focus
in particular on uh programs in large
language models and
Transformers modern paradigms and
generalizations and
cryptography um and then that will be
followed by Talks by our IND industry
Partners who are invited to present on
Research topics um that are particularly
connected to theoretical computer
science um after that uh we'll have a
lunch here at the Institute and then
we'll have a series of lightning talks
from our fantastic research fellows here
at the Institute um and finally we'll
end the day with two sessions um
organized by our current programs that
are related to uh the program on logic
and algorithms in database Theory and
as well as the program currently running
on data structures and optimizations for
fast algorithms and then we'll proceed
for dinner at The Faculty Club
here um so there's going to be a lot of
information coming at you today but
you'll be able to see almost all of it
later on our YouTube channel if you want
to check out a talk again um we hope the
day is informative and enjoyable um and
I just want to thank again our industry
partners for supporting the work and our
fellows um and we're always open to
adding more industry Partners if you're
interested so um and finally I'd like to
thank our dedicated staff for planning
the day and a particular importance
today is Carson sitting in the front
since she is our timekeeper so um she
will keep us all in order throughout the
day thank you Carson so um and uh
hopefully everyone will leave a little
bit of time at the end of their talks
for questions and discussion so
um all right so I think we're ready to
get started umash are you ready to take
it away and tell us about L large
language
models thank you um so